our latest wildflower is not just in
charge she's got a whole lot of spark
because she is an electrician
tanya hicks was the first
african-american woman to be accepted in
the mississippi
electrical union and the first woman
accepted in her
local union and tanya is joining us now
hi tanya
what made you want to be an electrician
yes i was in college and i wanted to
work in the pentagon and work on some
sci-fi
stuff and my professors said the best
thing i would be able to do
was to be a teacher that they want jobs
like that available for women
so that summer i was discouraged i went
and worked on a construction site
and i saw that the electrician you use
um
electricity all day and um
it was i knew right then that's when i
now you started your own business and
for 15 years
um you pretended that a man
ran your company why did you do that
well i wanted to be taken seriously and
i wanted to be paid equally
and usually when people find that you're
a woman they want to pay you
lesser and you you don't get the same
opportunity
so i would go to job sites they would
think i was the cleaning lady
and then when they would find out that i
was a woman and i was an owner
they don't automatically thought that i
owned the company
with my husband and i wasn't even there
and so i i used that as an opportunity
to hide so
i could build up my resume and
um also not make being a woman or
minority my value proposition
so i did that well
i am really excited to be your
apprentice today
will you teach me something i did not
know before
empower me pun intended oh yes
well today we're going to change out a
regular speech into a motion switch
and drew you have children just like i
do and you get tired of screaming at the
kids
trying to turn off the lights when you
install a motion switch
as long as there's no activity in the
room they're automatically found
so you're going to go all right teach me
the ways tanya
turn me into someone i've always wanted
to be
which is not the damsel in distress who
calls for help but can do
it myself so the first thing we're going
to do is we're going to make sure that
the power is set up
all right so here we go power off
so next thing you're going to do is take
your multi-purpose screwdriver
and to the flathead side and take the
switch off
turn to the left at the time same time
you're doing that
i'm going to talk about the switch when
you
take that plate off the switches you'd
have about
three wires to it a hot a switch leg
and a rounding wire
so the next thing that you want to do is
use the same
screwdriver to take out the top and the
bottom screws
and then just pull it on out
all right there we go
oh all right
okay drew great job next thing you want
to do is disconnect the wires
okay so do i want to take the caps off
yes you do
know the watermelons you want to take
those off okay and then i'm going to put
this in like this okay and then i'm
going to attach all the wires am i just
going like
red wire blue wire like classic movie
like attach the wires
that are matching yes you're going to
take the green wire and put the green
wire on the green on the wire with the
green screw
you're going to take your black wire and
connect it with the
wires coming out of the black now we've
already stripped these wires for you
so and they put you put some pigtails on
there what we call
it for you to get pigtails
okay right now you're doing great
yeah just put those wires on
and push it push all the way in the box
uh-huh and you see the screw at the top
of the screw at the bottom
you're gonna put you're gonna put those
screws on
yeah great job yeah
um yeah the entire job takes uh 10 to 15
minutes so this is awesome you're doing
great yes yes so now
[Music]
all right i'm going to flick the power
on
and then here we go ready
boom
um tanya if i
walk by a light switch now i feel
like i actually know what it looks like
inside
i know what to do i know what wires to
match
and i feel like i've seen something that
was completely mysterious to me before
and i thank you for
illuminating i did it again me
and to not feeling so helpless and
opening up a whole new world to me thank
you
you're welcome well thank you tanya
and we're honored to get the word out
about you you are such an inspiration
for
all the roads you are paving for
everyone else thank you so much
you're welcome thank you for having me
thank you tanya
you